[Music]
you are watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive in the next half hour
we'll see what's making the headlines
with guardian columnist zoe williams and
the spectators economics correspondent
kate andrews so let's see what's on some
of those front pages for you now
the telegraph says the prime minister is
planning to give tenants the right to
buy the homes they rent from housing
associations at a discounting price in
an attempt to alleviate the pressures on
generation rent
the daily mail calls on sakirstama to
provide proof he didn't break lockdown
rules himself during the event where he
allegedly drank beer with labor
activists in september of 2020
the financial times says chinese
regulators have held emergency meetings
with banks to assess how to protect
chinese assets from sanctions imposed by
the united states on russia
meanwhile the guardian reports that
thousands of dentists quitting their
jobs and dental practices closing and
going private has led to millions being
left without access to dental care
and the express says a record 2.7
million people joined the backlog for
cancer care and diagnosis during the
covid pandemic
and finally the daily star has a story
about the dangers dogs may face ahead of
the hot weather this summer with vets
urging owners to rub sun cream on their
dogs
and a reminder that by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us
and we are joined tonight by zoe
williams and kate andrews welcome to you
both let's start with the guardian your
paper zoe and this story on the front
page headline there bad apples claim
fuels parliament sexism rao
kate i'll get you to start us off with
this one
so
as the guardian is reporting and as
we've heard for weeks now um accusation
after accusation is coming in against
the culture of sleaze uh in westminster
pest mister as this be done to the past
feels like it's coming back and the
guardian is reporting that the
government is facing intense pressure
that it takes more action over the
misogyny and harassment um in quotes
here uh after a senior minister denied
institutional problems saying that there
were simply some bad apples i think one
of the difficulties here is that it is
very difficult when we start to
generalize terms like past ministers
suggest that everybody is caught up in
this and of course there are many many
good people working across whitehall but
like in every industry and every
institution you're going to come across
people who abuse their power and
manipulate those who are more junior to
them i think the difficulty in
westminster is that a lot of these
accusations haven't been taken as
seriously in the past as they should
have been calls for hr are never
properly brought in the structures are
unclear and it does seem that people who
are in the most powerful positions
feel sometimes inclined to abuse that
power and so when people say well it's
just some bad apples it doesn't go down
well because whilst of course it isn't
everybody who's taking part in a sleaze
culture if these issues have been raised
in the past and not properly addressed
it certainly doesn't feel like this is
just a one-off case it feels like
there's a systematic problem here that
needs to be tackled and for a government
uh that has now been in charge for well
over a decade uh to be acting for
anybody in that government to be acting
as if um this isn't their responsibility
to seriously look into this and fix
those institutional problems there's
going to be push back to that well
certainly labor warning of a toxic
culture aren't they zoe
listen i have to take issue with
something that kate just said this is
not every workplace you know i mean i
i
obviously i haven't worked in every
workplace but if you consider the facts
here you had
stella creasy on the one hand
um trying to lobbying to be able to
bring her baby in so she could
breastfeed in the house of commons while
somebody else is watching porn in the
house of commons i mean that is
absolutely unthinkable there's no way
that regular workplaces were going
through something like this there's no
way that normal workplaces were saying
oh well you know
one in ten mps one in ten of our workers
has some kind of sexual allegation
against them and yet this is functional
so
tracy brabin's comments
on friday do
you know
raise salience here it was the wild west
it still is the wild west in westminster
and it is in no way comparable to any
ordinary workplace so you know whether
you say it's a few bad apples whether
you say it's coming from the top whether
you say
it's a few bad apples who weren't
sufficiently dealt with the truth is
you will not be able to solve this until
you accept that it is a really really
unusual situation
kate i don't think you were saying it
was a few bad apples were you
no no i wasn't saying this too bad
apples that's what the guardians report
that a senior minister has suggested um
i did suggest that westminster isn't the
only place where you will find people
who abuse their power and um perhaps i
was more optimistic than i am and i
would like to be more optimistic but i
think realistically sector-wide you are
mostly going to find well-intentioned
people who respect their staff and
understand consent i think most adults
are capable of doing that you are always
going to find people who try to bend the
rules who don't respect others
and i think that you do i you know i
broadly speaking agree with zoe that you
might find more of that in westminster
than you would in certain other sectors
but i think if you speak to women in
finance if you speak to people in the
city
you'll find that people who end up in
very high positions of power sometimes
feel immune like they can abuse it and
the problem with language like it's a
few bad apples isn't that westminster is
the only place where this happens it's
certainly not um but that westminster
famously has issues with its systems and
a lack of hr this does happen in other
sectors but it's usually cracked down on
very very quickly because there are
clear structures that don't tolerate
this kind of thing and men and women
know exactly where they can go and what
they need to do to report this behavior
this has been an issue for bullying in
westminster as well the structures just
have not been clear and it's very rare
that i call for for more bureaucracy i i
personally wouldn't want to work for an
organization that was very hr heavy but
you need certain fundamental structures
and systems in place so that women and
men know where to go when they're when
power is being used against them um it's
very very long westminster hasn't done
this properly so
i don't think is the question of i
honestly don't think this is a question
of not knowing where to go and not
having systems in place i think this is
a question of absolute impunity and and
it is quite serious you know
it's not the case that female mps were
too clueless or too ignorant or lack the
ability to go somewhere and complain it
is actually extremely weird
let's move on let's move on because we
want to get some other papers in let's
uh move on to the mail let's move on to
the mail and this moving on from from
partygate to beergate and that there's a
call now for sakirstama to provide uh
summer proof regarding beergate take us
into this kate
well kiosama is under a lot of pressure
based on whatever happened in durham in
september 2020. he has uh he has been
cleared um the the durham police decided
that he hadn't broken lockdowns but
there is emerging evidence increasing
suggestion that something far more fun
was happening around this pub quiz um
and uh around the pub quiz that was it
was it was undiscovered was taking place
the um the front of the mail suggests
that perhaps there was a mass order of
curry and takeaway involved in this
evening and people simply aren't buying
the idea that this was simply a work
event now the difficulty here and is
that because we are retrospectively
deciding that we're going to prosecute
these fines
and and we're going to have different
police forces up and down the country
doing so we're going to be getting a lot
of different results um and i think it's
quite right that the accusations in
westminster and number 10 in particular
are taken most seriously these are of
course the people who were setting the
rules for them to be breaking them as
the most egregious but given the fact
that very junior people are now reported
to be getting fines for the leader of
the opposition to potentially escape a
fine is not going to go down well either
so as more evidence emerges that perhaps
a little bit too much fun was being had
when it was illegal for others to be
doing so pressure is going to increase
on the labor party especially if they
want to keep going on about party gay it
is more difficult for the labor party to
do that
standing out we are running out of time
but zoe just just come back there no but
let me just cut in in 2020 in september
2020 the lockdown rules weren't the same
we were already allowed to meet in in
completely different configurations by
that time so
the idea that the labour party has
broken the rules in the same way it's
completely fanciful and kate i'm amazed
you don't know that well no nobody's
saying it was the same accusation as
that they we have we have to take a
break
in september 2020. we have to take a
break ladies but just suffice to say
that secure says he was working and his
team only stopped for a break for food
before resuming their duties we are
going to take a break don't worry we'll
get more time when you come back
coming up foul play blow to family
budgets as cost of a chicken is set to
soar as high as beef that's the headline
in tomorrow's daily mirror we'll be
discussing that next
[Music]
back you're watching the press preview
still with me guardian columnist zoe
williams and the spectators economics
correspondent kate andrews let's have a
look at the financial times going to
take us to france and uh their mayday
protest traditional um macron
hardly stepped back into position but uh
he's being protested against in france
kate actually no zoe zoe you bring us
into this
well i did
basically the trades union movement in
france and the left in general is trying
to hold macron's feet to the fire and
they do so not just because it's
international workers day today happy
international workers day but because
they the left basically saved macron
from defeat you know melancholics votes
even though many of them said they
weren't going to vote at all
the
the the ones that counted went to macron
rather than le pen and so he did triumph
on left-wing votes basically and now
they're saying
you need to reflect the fact that our
support has put you where you are and
that's something that he
arguably failed to reflect in his first
term
kate let's take uh viewers to the mirror
and this is the cost of living crisis
again demonstrated in the fact that uh
chicken is now going to cost as much as
beef at sword in in price
yes this is the warning on the front
page of the mirror that chicken could
soon cost as much as beef um as supply
chain issues and inflation are rearing
their ugly head again um and you know
this is uh once again a a very difficult
reality of what happens when prices
start to soar and in some ways you know
this is a this is an international issue
every developed economy is dealing um
with quite serious inflation um but the
reality for people is that it means
price is going up it means some very
difficult choices for those at the lower
end of the pay spectrum
and the biggest issue is that this is
going to get worse before it gets better
i mean we haven't seen the peak of
inflation yet um it could be double
digit figures uh and that means
extremely difficult choices in the next
six months indeed it could be the first
time the price has been the same um as
beef for about 70 years
kate and
zoe thank you both for taking us through
the papers we'll see you the next hour